economista de profesión y natural del
distrito del carmen en costa rica
rodrigo chávez obtuvo un doctorado
económico en la universidad de ohio lo
que le abrió las puertas al banco
mundial donde trabajó durante más de 25
años
en 2019
el político renunció a su cargo y volvió
a costa rica comenzó su carrera política
al ser fichado para ocupar el ministerio
de hacienda puesto que desempeñó durante
184 días y del que también terminó
renunciando no fue hasta 2021 cuando
anunció que se unía al partido social
democrático desde donde ha defendido
políticas conservadoras con un discurso
nacionalista y a favor de la
recuperación económica del país a través
de pactos con organismos como el fm el
actual acuerdo negociado puede mejorarse
de acuerdo a los intereses del país y
que yo estoy muy anuente al renegociar
con el compromiso de que no incluirá más
impuestos en su corta trayectoria
política chávez ya se ha visto envuelto
en varias polémicas el mismo año que
abandonó el banco mundial este lo
sancionó por acoso sexual a dos de sus
trabajadores entre 2008 y 2013 y
recientemente el periódico wall street
journal publicó que chávez también
habría acosado a mujer en indonesia
entre 2018 y 2019
acusaciones que siempre ha negado el
periodista quien tardó 12 semanas para
escribir la nota afirma que hubo una
conducta inapropiada necesidad de
indolencia y sabes como sustenta esa
temeraria afirmación con gente
familiarizada con el caso
el político muy popular entre los
costarricenses también ha sido señalado
por financiar su campaña con cuentas
bancarias no declaradas